[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal local
voici les titres de ce mercredi 29 mars
la campagne des élections législatives
déjà lancé sur la 11e circonscription
des yvelines jean michel fourgous le
maire d'elancourt et candidat de la
droite a présenté aujourd'hui ses
différents axes de campagne emploi
éducation et sécurité un programme pour
tenter de reconquérir une
circonscription actuellement détenue par
benoît hamon candidat ps à la
présidentielle
attrape des habitants s'opposent au
projet d'enfouissement partielle de la
n10 objet de la discorde avec la mairie
la création de deux rond point à
proximité de leur terrain des ronds
points qu'ils jugent notamment dangereux
pour leur sécurité
enfin dans ce journal de la biodiversité
à saint-cyr-l'ecole les fermes de gally
mène depuis plusieurs mois une étude
pour comprendre l'alimentation des
abeilles
objectif mieux les protéger alors qu'une
grande partie de notre alimentation en
dépend je vous le disais en titre la
campagne présidentielle bat actuellement
son plein en coulisses les partis
s'activent déjà pour le troisième tour
celui des élections législatives avec en
toile de fond la majorité pour le ou la
futur président ou présidente dans la
11e circonscription des yvelines le
maire d'elancourt jean michel fourgous
entend bien retrouver son poste perdu en
2012 avant à en 2012 excusez moi au
profit d'un certain benoît hamon
wilfried richie et pat jacques de
dixmude lancement officiel de campagne
pour le maire d'elancourt dans la 11e
circonscription face à la presse en
cette fin mars jean michel fourgous a
annoncé partir à la reconquête d'un
poste occupé de 1993 à 1997 puis de 2002
à 2012 axes principaux de sa campagne
l'emploi la sécurité et l'éducation
ces trois sujets sur lequel bien entendu
beaucoup d'arbitrage qui dépendent de
national donc c'est pour ça que j'y vais
j'ai déjà des reins
un groupe de 150 députés qui s'appelle
génération entreprises dont je suis le
porte parole
j'ai écrit déjà vingt propositions dont
bien sûr j'ai envie de les mettre en
place une revue donc c'est très bien si
demain je vais député-maire
effectivement ça va vite parce que tout
est prêt le candidat de la droite et du
centre pourrait affronter le sortant
benoît hamon reste à connaître les
résultats de l'élection présidentielle
dans laquelle ce dernier s'est engagé en
2012 il l'avait emporté sur cette
circonscription qui couvre notamment les
communes de bois d'arcy elancourt la
verrière le mesnil saint denis ou encore
trappe avec 55% des voix
il est trop dans la triche ce garçon il
a la culture de la triche sur ses
diplômes sur les eaux sales femmes sur
sur son habitation sur sur sur l'emploi
sur il a dit qu'il avait fait ça ou
vérifier c'est pas assez ajoute qu'il a
fait il s'attribue le travail des autres
bons c'est compliqué c'est un garçon qui
pose un problème je trouve au moins de
confiance également candidats déjà
déclarés dans cette circonscription luc
miserait élu communiste d'opposition
attrape ou encore mathilde andrew est
élu front national au conseil régional
et puisque l'on évoque benoît hamon
sachez que le candidat à la
présidentielle doit faire face au
soutien de plusieurs ténors socialistes
à son concurrent emmanuel macron ce
matin c'est manuel valls l'ancien
premier ministre qui a déclaré qu'il
voterait lors du premier tour en faveur
du candidat en marche benoît hamon lui
connaît du coup actuellement un passage
difficile dans sa campagne le candidat
ps plafonne autour des 10 % dans les
sondages et appelle au rassemblement
avec jean luc mélenchon une réunion
d'ailleurs se doit se tenir rapidement
entre les deux hommes
écoutez un benoît - ce propos tout le
monde sait que par mon projet tourné
vers la sixième république vers la
transition écologique vers le travail
vers l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat
et la refondation de l'europe
tout le monde sait que par mon projet à
la fois transformateurs et sérieux j'ai
une position centrale à gauche et que je
suis le seul à pouvoir conjuguer des
électorats différents des radicaux aux
plus modérés alors pas le conseil
municipal a voté hier soir le budget
primitif
2010 est un budget de près de 40
millions d'euros en légère hausse par
rapport à l'an passé
pas de hausse en revanche des impôts
locaux et 7 millions d'euros dédiés aux
travaux d'investissement parmi les
premiers projets phares cette année la
modernisation des écoles des friches de
la marnière et de la joie ou encore de
plusieurs équipements culturels et
sportifs
dans le reste de l'actualité locale le
projet d'enfouissement partielle de la
n10 déjà contesté attrape alors que la
commission denquête a remis son rapport
favorable
il y a quelques semaines au préfet des
yvelines des riverains contestent les
travaux prévus près de chez eux et la
création notamment de deux ronds points
en entrée et sortie de ville des ronds
points dangereux pour leur sécurité
selon le reportage toute cette zone là
c'est le rond-point cesser leur emploi
le rond point il est mis dans le champ
il ne décolère pas ses habitants de
trappes s'opposent depuis plusieurs
semaines à la création d'un futur
rond-point à quelques mètres seulement
de leur jardin
ici à l'intersection de la nationale 10
et la route départementale 23 un projet
inscrit dans le cadre de l'enfouissement
partiel de la n10 présenté comme une
amélioration de l'insertion urbaine par
la commune ces habitants niveau eu que
des problèmes à pollution le bruit les
accélérations les coups de klaxon même
même les gyrophares dépoli de police de
pompiers
c'est c'est intenable s'est déjà
intenable actuellement donc le long de
nos os et c'est pas possible ça va être
insupportable pour la cinquantaine de
riverains concernés l'enfouissement
partiel prévue sur 400 m doit être
prolongée sur l' axe de son côté la
mairie qui porte ce projet depuis
presque 20 ans n'a pas voulu répondre à
nos questions
le maire ne souhaite pas répondre pour
le moment et le fera une fois la
déclaration d'utilité publique publiée
en effet il ne souhaite pas répondre sur
des travaux dont le maître d'oeuvre est
l'état attrape les nuisances causées par
la n 10 ont dénoncé depuis la création
de lacs ce milieu des années 50 jusqu'à
80 mille véhicules par jour l'empreinte
en direction de paris ou de rambouillet
les premiers travaux devraient débuter
en 2018 pour un coût total de 95
millions d'euros à versailles le nouveau
centre de protection maternelle et
infantile a été officiellement inaugurée
hier situé rue jean vous scelle cette
nouvelle pmi regroupe trois sites qui
étaient a précédemment éclaté sur la
commune 2000 enfants devraient en
bénéficier cette inauguration s'inscrit
dans le plan de restructuration des pmi
lancé il ya deux ans par le département
des yvelines
objectif moderniser l'offre pour
améliorer le service rendu à la
population écoutez à ce propos la
directrice de l'établissement le dr
martina garcin au micro de semaine
vendredi la réunion des pays med a été
décidée au niveau politique dans une
politique globale de réduction du nombre
de centres de pmi sur le département sur
la ville de versailles il y avait trois
pmi à vauban à jussieu et à l'impasse
des gendarmes
et il a été décidé d'ouvrir un seul
centre avec pour but d'élargir les
amplitudes horaires de façon qu' on
puisse offrir un service tous les jours
aux usagers et c'est ce qui a été fait
depuis le 16 janvier 2007 17 nous avons
ouvert les portes de ce nouveau centre
un chiffre alarmant à présent dans
l'actualité
30% des colonies d'abeilles
disparaissent chaque année en france en
cause les pesticides ou les carences en
alimentation un constat inquiétant donc
qui a poussé les fermes de gally à
s'engager pour la sauvegarde des
abeilles
depuis septembre les fermes n une étude
pour comprendre leur alimentation avec
un spécialiste
reportage de camille lambert
ce sont de véritables ouvrière dans un
rayon pouvant aller jusqu'à 3 km une
abeille est capable de butiner 500
fleurs par jour genre de chasse va les
responsables des ruchers de la ferme de
gally après l'hiver ils vérifient l'état
des ruches c'est la découverte première
visite de printemps on regarde ce qui
s'est passé pendant l'hiver
on va regarder les réserves qui reste il
n'est ce pas grand chose dans cette
ruche
mais on constate quand même il ya
beaucoup de pollen et ça c'est du jeune
pollen qui a été récolté depuis le mois
de février
cette ruche est en bonne santé mais ce
n'est pas le cas partout
chaque année 30 % des colonies
d'abeilles disparaissent en cause les
pesticides les maladies mais aussi le
manque de nourriture depuis septembre
2016 les fermes de gally mène une étude
avec le docteur kim nguyen spécialiste
des abeilles
une colonne d'abaisser cinquante mille
abeilles elles vont collecter le 4
milliards d'échantillons dans leur
environnement sur 700 hectares avons
ramené tous à l'intérieur de la ruche et
nous allons analyser l'eau collectée ou
sly analyses en laboratoire en fonction
des résultats qu'on a obtenus on peut
vous dire voilà il ya des pesticides
quelles sont les mesures qu'on peut
prendre avec les agriculteurs pour
limiter l'usagé des pesticides
on a retrouvé les carences alimentaires
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire mais on fait
des plantations avec des citoyens comme
ici on va le faire ici et notamment des
plantations pour nourrir les abeilles en
période creuse les fermes de gally
sensibilise le public à privilégier les
plantes qui fleurissent à différents
moments céanothes brouyère aux myosotis
elles vont aller dans le jardin de
chacun sur le balcon pour pouvoir
butiner ces plantes mellifères qui
doivent fleurir de bus début de la
saison mais aussi jusqu'à la fin de
l'automne nourrir les abeilles pour
qu'elle puisse nourrir un cycle vertueux
le résultat de l'étude sera connu fin
c'est la première de ce type en ile de
france c'est un marché estimé à près de
deux milliards d'euros et qui ne connaît
pas la crise le café était mise à
l'honneur récemment le comité français
du café organisé deux journées
d'animations et de découvertes
l'événement a fédéré 300 torréfacteur du
territoire et parmi eux
la boutique saveurs des comptoirs à
voisins le bretonneux l'occasion vous
allez le voir de déguster un excellent
café froid avec ce reportage de nicolas
d'ambré le café en fait dans la boutique
saveurs des comptoirs d'amérique latine
d'afrique ou d'asie mme quinzaine de
grands crus vendus dans ce magasin pour
les journées du café une préparation à
l'eau froide et proposés à la
dégustation
une curiosité apprécié on sent vraiment
la délicatesse des arts on se sent
beaucoup plus léger ici avec les cafés
c'est effectivement c'est une boisson
très désaltérante et on conçoit qu'on
puisse boire ça toute la journée par
grosses chaleurs c'est la première fois
que je bois en fait un café froid c'est
à dire on
c'est pas un café chaud qui a refroidi
froid 5 a fait infuser à froid elle
s'est complètement c'est une autre de
sensations à l'honneur une variété de
café indonésien de sulawesi les grains
sont d'abord mou lui verser à
l'intérieur d'une cafetière puis refuser
ces journées du café sont organisées par
un regroupement de torréfacteurs
français occasion pour thomas jouvenot
de faire découvrir les secrets de son
métier fait on utilise pour ça une
machine qui va apporter les grains en
température jusqu'à 200 degrés à
l'intérieur du tambour
cette température va être être montée va
être progressive et on va passer par
différentes phases différentes façons
était vraiment la torréfaction qui va
permettre de développer plus faveur et
que l'art au monde
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
nouvelle édition des journées du café
afin d'éveiller nos papilles gustatives
on reste à voisins le bretonneux pour
refermer ce journal jusqu'à dimanche la
ville rassemble les lauréats des deux
dernière biennale de peinture et de
sculpture huit artistes du territoire
présentent leurs oeuvres
encre pastel métal ou bois tout un
univers à l'espace de coville parmi les
tableaux à découvrir ceux de brigitte
whitechurch elle est professeur au
centre alfred de vigny et dévoile son
travail autour du papier
je fais une première trame une première
peau enfin du tableau avec toutes sortes
de papiers j'ai un point de départ une
idée de départ et ensuite je restructure
avec du fusain et je peins et ensuite je
recolle je repeins je fais parfois des
pochoirs aussi c'est très agréable parce
que on découvre le travail aussi tout
l'univers aussi d autres artistes
on a des échanges avec eux c'est la fin
de ce 7 8 le journal tous nos reportages
sont à retrouver en replay et sur tv fil
78 points comme ou l'application tv fils
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]